we are joined now from delaware by jill
biden dr biden if you please just hours
after her convention speech
good morning to you dr biden it's good
to see you
good morning gail i i want to talk about
last night because
listen your the biden family has had two
uh presidential campaigns that didn't
work out
uh joe biden was vice president and now
you all
are in striking distance of the white
house what does this moment mean to you
and your family
you know joe has worked so hard i think
to to be
at this moment and uh you know he did
run twice before but this time we're
gonna win
and you say that with such confidence
why
because i think you know i think our
country is looking for new leadership
and they're looking for someone who's
steady and
strong and has the character to lead us
forward
and that's joe that's my husband joe
you gave very touching analogies uh last
night about the family tragedies and
uniting a family and now uniting a
country
uh michelle obama said the other day
that donald trump is not the man who can
meet this moment
what did you make of her speech as you
were watching it because as you know
she said out loud to everyone i hate
politics
but it was a very political very
heartfelt speech what were you thinking
as you were watching it
you know i love michelle's speech i
thought that uh she was strong she spoke
from her heart
and i think you know it resonated with
all americans i
i just love her positive energy and uh
so i you know she's such a great role
model for
for everyone really you're in such a
unique position dr biden because listen
it's well known how much you love
teaching
how much you love your career how much
your students love you
we are in such a very vulnerable place
in this country about
kids going back to school whether it's
safe to go should they go
the president says it's time what are
your thoughts as we sit here and decide
what is right for america's children
you know gail i mean i hear from
educators and parents
every single day and everybody is
wondering what should we do
what should we do and you know the
answer is that we have to listen to the
doctors and the scientists and the
experts
and when they say it's safe to go back
then let's go back because
no one wants to be back in the classroom
more than educators and i can tell you
that from first-hand experience
you know in the tape last night you said
when joe biden became a vice president
you had to step it up
you had to kick it up a notch if you
become first lady of this country
what do you have to do what are your
what are you thinking
you know i'm thinking that i'm going to
continue with the platforms that i
and the issues that i've always worked
on you know
raising military families working with
educators and teachers
and uh working hard for free community
college and of course our cancer
initiative
now you can do this that's not a
republican issue will you continue oh
yes
i will continue teaching in the
classroom you'll go every day i'm a
teacher
that's who i am that's who i am
let's talk about the biden harris ticket
uh
because many people thought how will joe
biden be able to get past
the kerfuffle that they had in the
debate and the bigger question is
how will dr jill biden get past that as
a wife of someone
who many people felt was unfairly
attacked during the debate
how did you get past that because the
thinking is he would not have picked
kamala harris
had you not signed off on it you know
joe really admires strong women
and i think uh kamala is a a strong
woman
woman she's fear she's tough and uh
that's what we need going forward and so
uh
when joe chose a woman and chose kamala
i was
really excited so um i think it's a
great ticket
and i and that's what we're hearing from
all americans that uh
you know that they love having her on
the ticket president trump has
questioned joe biden's mental fitness
and his cognitive skills
what do you want us to know about that
you know i mean joe is working so hard
every day i mean he's taking calls from
governors and talking to nancy pelosi
and
uh schumer and you know he's getting
he's
on the zoom from nine in the morning
till 10 11 at night because of course we
have to
talk to people in california as well you
know he's doing fundraising and
briefings and
so he's i i there's no
question about that joe is busy every
minute of the day
all right joe biden the campaign's just
getting underway you can't campaign the
way you'd like to you can't connect with
people
face to face how do you intend to
connect with people under these
circumstances and then we'll let you go
gail we are connecting with thousands
of people every day joe and i are
zooming ever to into every state into
every constituency
we're meeting all kinds of people all
across this nation
so thousands of people a day so yes we
miss
campaigning because that's you know joe
loves it that's who he is but um we're
doing it virtually we're staying safe
i call i'm all zoomed out i don't know
about you oh one more thing i saw on the
tape
your grandchildren described you as not
your typical grandmother
they said that you are the type your
prankster you wake them up at five
o'clock
to go soul cycling i call that child
abuse on christmas eve
what do you what do you want us to know
about you jill biden as a grandmother
i love that you know i i my grandmother
was such a great role model for me and i
just
you know and that's who i wanted to be i
wanted to i wanted
them i wanted to be fun for them and uh
so
i try to interject a little you know a
little levity a little fun
into their lives yeah we could all have
a lot of fun these days we could all use
a little fun
joe biden we'll see you on the campaign
a little joy yes
thank you so much for taking that scale
thank you good to see you
thank you